welcome once again to a special program
about the war in ukraine over the next
hour we'll be attempting to answer your
questions about the war with defence and
security analyst professor michael clark
well fierce fighting continues in the
donbass region in the east of ukraine
russia has told ukrainian troops in
several donetsk to surrender tomorrow
morning calling their resistance
senseless the last bridge between the
city and ukrainian-held territory has
apparently been destroyed by russian
forces but ukraine's troops continue to
hold out well as i say professor michael
clark joins me in the studio welcome
once again uh michael will crack on with
the questions we've had so many of them
during the course of today and the first
question concerns that situation of
course in the donbass christian asked do
you think we are
coming to the end game and the end game
in russia's favor no um it's got a fair
way to go yet i mean if the russians
keep up this momentum this this slow
gradual grinding momentum then they
probably will take most of the donbass
eventually but the word is eventually
they haven't taken severe donetsk yet
which is the capital of luhansk which is
the smaller of the two oblasts the two
areas of the donbass region and the
ukrainians are making them pay to take
severe donetsk everyone is saying you
know reporters are out there and they're
saying this is the critical moment well
it's not
um the strategically important city the
two strategically important cities are
slaviyansk and kramatosk further in the
in the west those have to be defended
and the ukrainians at the moment are
fighting against vera jones to make the
russians pay a price before they pull
back i think first of all telishi shan's
on the other side of the river because
the russians have still got across the
river the severity it's very don the
saverski donetsk river they've struggled
across that river in force and they
haven't yet they've made a real mess of
it twice and ukrainians will have time
to fall back on their real strategic
objective which are the two cities of
slavians and cremators what about this
bridge reportedly being destroyed does
that make that plan
yeah i mean there's several there are
several bridges and a lot of them have
been destroyed and partially rebuilt it
doesn't mean that the ukrainians are
trapped it may mean that they can't
bring their equipment with them but they
can always get troops over a river then
get them over in boats they can get them
over on makeshift bridges they can throw
military bridges over a river create
pontoon bridges it's always vulnerable
if you do that but this doesn't stop the
troops escaping it may mean that they
can't take their heavy equipment with
them in which case they would disable it
and then leave well michael you
mentioned they're making the russians
pay a heavy price but our next question
now asks i suppose but at what price for
the ukrainian forces uh this one that
asks um how long can
ukraine continue to lose troops
there it is that was the main pavlo grab
bridge that went down about three weeks
ago and that was the biggest bridge the
best bridge and that was down but
they've worked their way around it pavlo
grad was the main one but not it doesn't
matter okay but in terms in terms of the
troop losses by ukrainians you know
president zielinski says they're losing
what one to 200 a day 3000 a month they
are and they can't sustain that for very
long but so are the russians russian
losses seem to be about the same level i
mean russian losses you were much higher
than ukrainian losses in the other
battles of kiev and kharkiv and so on
now that this is a real second world war
style toe-to-toe match in the donbass
they're fighting in a sort of almost
1940s 50s way
their losses are about in the streets
blockbuster absolutely block by block
hand-to-hand it's it's i mean it's it's
about as dreadful as you can ever
imagine from a soldier's point of view
and their losses are about about the
same neither of them can sustain 3 000 a
month for very much longer so there will
be a pause there will be a pause while
both sides take a breath and can i just
ask you does that matter of fighting
does that negate the russian advantage
when it comes to artillery and
long-range because you can't really
attack
the other side if they're cheated by joe
of course no that's right i mean one of
the reasons that ukrainians have stayed
toe to toe with the russians just to
stop them using their artillery but what
the russians have been doing is
flattening everything in front of them
and then they walk in over uh over the
rubble i mean the the one thing the
russians are good at which they always
were and they've proven that they
haven't got anything else in their
locker than this really which is to
flatten um urban areas and then as it
were invade the rubble and if if another
side in this case ukrainians are
prepared to fight in the rubble and the
ukrainian army is good enough to do that
then even that's not straightforward so
they can keep destroying areas but their
progress is extremely slow extremely
slow we all expected them to be to be
even for russians we expect them to be a
lot quicker than they've been i mean
some of them they sometimes they're
making less than a kilometer a day and
some days not even that and some days
they're getting pushed back and they're
they're drawing more and more troops
into this very donetsk into this
particular battle and they're getting
thinner and thinner in the north in
kharkiv in the south incursion well
that's the next question i wanted to ask
you about so moving on then to the south
as you mentioned there kershaw nick
wants to know will ukraine manage to
finally break through and retake kersham
because it seems the russians have never
been able to to entirely pacify they
haven't and there's a lot of um
resistance in kershawn and molitopol a
lot of a lot of what the russians will
call terrorism now against russian
troops and collaborators and so on it's
pretty ugly stuff and it's breaking out
on the streets of kirsh on the streets
of malibu
the ukrainians say that they think they
are going to retake cursion i mean i
think there might be a bit optimistic
about that but they have launched a
pretty big offensive across a 50-mile
front and they've crossed the inulits
river again crossing rivers is really
important in military terms they've
crossed the inulits river to the north
uh west of kershan and they're trying to
get round the back of russian troops
incursion while they also
attack them from the west
so that they're trying a two-pronged
attack against kershawn and what they're
finding is that the russians are now
pretty thin in cursion because they've
taken a lot of troops away for this
donbass offensive
and i don't know if the ukrainians are
being too optimistic about this because
even having crossed the inhilits river
they're still 40 miles away from the
city but unlike the russians more like
western forces the ukrainians make rapid
progress they move quickly and they move
efficiently when they do move so we'll
see i mean i i think in the next couple
of weeks we'll find out if this
offensive against kershawn to retake
cursion is going to be a success or not
okay well let's stay in the south
because our next question follows on
from that situation louis wants to know
do you think mikolav and odessa are the
next targets after don bass or kharkiv
and dinipro so
if don bass is relatively secured by
russia
where would it turn its sights next i
think the answer to lewis is yes exactly
mickelev and odessa are more important
strategic targets for the russians
because to take odessa would landlock
ukraine it would it would make ukraine a
landlocked country i mean the russians
remember they've all already got
mario pole
they control the sea of azov they've got
berdyansk those ports on the other side
of crimea to the east of crimea the big
port to the west of crimea of course is
odessa and that's that's
the third city it's ukraine's third city
so yes they want they need to take
nikolayev because mikolive is the
gateway to odessa even though it's 80
miles away so they've got to take
nicolaive and then they've got to cover
the 80 miles to odessa
um and those are big objectives they've
completely failed once they've been
thrown back from nicolaive which is why
they're now struggling to hold on to
cursion it seems but if they could then
release the troops in the donbass give
them a break
and then redeploy them to this area then
i'm sure their next uh strategic
objective would be to complete this land
bridge all the way across southern
ukraine well that's quite a big if isn't
it if they take the donbass and redeploy
the troops which has risks in itself in
that you've got to occupy territory and
the
rest and deployment takes a long time it
does and that's why i mean i i think you
know people keep asking me about what i
think is going to happen um and i guess
we're going to talk about it a bit later
on maybe but um
the ukrainians have shown they can fight
the russians to a standstill more or
less anywhere in ukraine
what they can't obviously do is kick
them out take back the territory that
they've lost they're trying but that's a
different sort of objective and so i
think that they could i think the
ukrainians will be pretty successful at
defending odessa even if the russians
can redeploy from the donbass in say two
months time
i think they will but we will say
warfare is
more unpredictable in sport
indeed okay a couple of questions coming
up about uh the air battles and uh ken
wants to know why aren't ukrainian
forces attacking russia from the air
because in the past in these programs
we've discussed how there are
still ukrainian air force there are
planes in the air they've got about half
of their air force left they started
with about 120 combat aircraft they seem
to have about 50 or so
uh left they're getting some more the
mig-29s but they the mig-29s are an air
combat aircraft um
for fighting against other aircraft
they're not really a ground attack
aircraft the the su-25s are the one that
are ground attack and so to attack
russian forces from the air it they need
more su-25s and they are getting some of
those
but remember they're also attacking the
russians from the air with drones so the
bairachter drone this turkish drone
which costs one twentieth of the cost of
an american or a british drone i mean
they're cheap and cheerful but they work
and the point about bay reactors is it's
not that they're any great technological
breakthrough just that you can have lots
of them and if you can have lots of them
you can obliterate whatever's on the
ground even if you lose half of them so
the bay rafter drones have been
extremely successful they've got lots of
other sorts of drones even tiny ones or
little copters that drop a grenade and
on a little group of soldiers who don't
even hear it drops a grenade and there's
any amount of footage that shows exactly
that happening so they are attacking
them from the air um but you know
russian forces have got their own air
defense the ukrainians are losing
aircraft and they they do need i mean
they do need to to rework their air
force if they're going to stay in this
war over the next months and into next
year well mark asks the other side of
the coin now about
russian forces in the air why has russia
not committed more of its air force to
the war for both bombing and ground
attack missions presumably i mean
they've got a huge air force we
mentioned that from the start of the
campaign they have yeah i mean they're
active the combat air air power is not
much more to be honest than about 800
aircraft it's not the three or four
thousand that are there on paper uh even
five thousand by some estimates but it's
more it's more like up to a thousand and
it's more likely to be by some estimates
as low as 750 800 850.
however um and and they committed about
230 240 to this operation at the
beginning they've clearly committed more
than that now their problem is not the
number of airframes they've got
available it's the ability of their
pilots and their command system to do
air ground coordination
so um even with more aircraft they find
it difficult actually to bomb things on
the ground and they're lousy really
lousy at bombing moving targets and it's
not because they can't aim um as they
work it but but the idea of getting
moving targets is that first of all
you've got to detect the movement then
you've got to see the target get
somebody
back at base to understand there's an
aircraft within 30 miles get that
aircraft over the target before it
disappears now western air forces are
very good at that well i mean it's not
down to
humans or technology it's it's both it's
training they've got the technologies
but they haven't trained for it they've
done so little air ground support um
exercises it seems in the past and so
that they have a command problem is that
although they can bomb fixed targets the
way anybody can bomb fixed targets i
mean reasonably accurately reasonably
they haven't got many precision guided
weapons i mean the the j dams these are
the bombs the joint attack demolition
munitions which are bombs that can be
directed they free fall but they can be
directed left or right and so on um they
haven't got many of those so they drop
dumb bombs second world war bombs that
they go wherever they go according to
how the pilot releases them so they drop
a lot of those but they still can't use
really accurate weaponry to get onto a
target within a couple of minutes of
discovering that it's moving along the
road and you want to get it
and ukrainians are very good at doing
that that well let's talk about those
targets that the ukrainians are hitting
because uh another question from mark
not sure if it's the same one but uh
mark asks what happened to the russian
t2 tanks we heard so much about well
that tell us it's much feared tea too
what's happening what's it terminator
are they there yeah it's not actually a
tank it's it's a bmp it's called a bmp2
the terminator 2. it's a tank insofar as
it's it's on a tank chassis it's on a
t-72 standard tank chassis
and um you know it's often said that a
camel
is a horse designed by a committee
well this is a
an armored fighting vehicle designed by
a committee they've taken a tank chassis
and they've piled onto it all of the
weapons that soldiers say they want so
there it is it's got two 30 millimeter
cannons it's got four rocket launchers
at the back it's got two grenade
launchers it's got a heavy machine gun
it's got smoke grenade launchers it's
got everything on it and the crew is all
inside doing all this remotely now i've
never been inside one of these things
very few people have i i can't imagine
what it's like inside because the amount
of transmission belts the amount of
ammunition that must be going backwards
and forwards while these things are
available is staggering
the russians have been boasting about
this for a long time they had them
available at the um
at the may day parade i think was in
2018 and it broke down um and they
haven't been at the mayday parades until
this year and this year they were due to
have three and only two turned up so we
think that one of those broke down as
well
they've only got one troop of these
terminator twos these bmps um and that
troop was been sent to svere donetsk and
that is either eight or ten
so we think the mod thinks it's only
eight
others have said it's probably ten but
at most they've got ten of these things
they've sent mrs philia donetsk we
haven't yet heard how they're getting on
but i suspect it's a camel i suspect
it's as vulnerable as any other t-72
even though it's got all this weaponry
piled on top of it so you think some of
them would be knocked out someone that
probably broken down
i'm very interested to hear how they've
been getting on i mean they've been
there now for over two weeks they don't
they haven't turned the battle that's
for sure okay um last question for this
section and uh interesting one this um
from em
why is there so
little incredibly little front line
combat footage one might almost be
tempted to wonder if it's all made up
well that bit uh no it's not um but uh
there is that question why is there so
incredibly little frontline combat
footage why isn't it emerging and you
know in an age of social media who's
controlling it oh damn it there is and i
mean and you know you know i mean sky's
got lots of this stuff and it doesn't
use it for reasons of propriety and
decency and we see and those of us who
are in this analysis business we see it
all the time uh look i'm looking at this
stuff all the time on twitter and not on
youtube particularly but other sources
and a lot of it's horrible it's horrible
um so yes there is plenty of footage
um it's not that this is being invented
in some way or that there isn't a lot of
material there's masses of material
and a lot of it is just too nasty to
want to spread around um and so what we
see is
um you know what's available and what
the news channels choose to to put out
but i mean you know you've seen some of
the stuff as well it's it's well there
is that argument though isn't it that in
a way it kind of sanitizes water as you
say you know it's it's brutal it's
horrible yeah do you know the person who
said that most was norman schwarzkopf
remember stormy norman from the gulf war
of 1991 and he said i can't remember the
exact phrase something like war is
ultimately obscene it is obscene and
disgusting when you're in it
and and it is i mean warfare brings out
some of the best of human nature and a
great deal of the worst
and i mean anybody who's been in fire
fights you know real close firefights
not remote artillery duels whatever
anyone that's been in firefights you
know
will never ever forget it and will
always be marked by the experience and
even you know
artillery and people look you see films
and people sort of duck down to the
foxholes and explosions going i mean if
an artillery shell lands anything within
about 50 yards the shrapnel flies all
over the place and so quite a lot of
people will be injured or killed within
about 50 yards of one shell landing you
know they say i mean you know sitting
under an
under an artillery barrage is one of the
most frightening things you could ever
do because of the sheer extent of the
shrapnel the reality of warfare and it's
certainly
not made up um we're taking a break
you're watching sky news coming up we're
going to be discussing then vladimir
putin's aims and what victory could now
be looking like for the russian
president
[Music]
welcome back we're going to turn now to
vladimir putin and uh what his
objectives may be now after initially
attempting to remember to seize the
capital kiev in the early days of the
war what does victory perhaps now look
like for the russian president michael
clark as you know is here answering
those questions and uh let's kick off
with this one from ian which is the
state which has been asked an awful lot
about uh of vladimir putin's health uh
michael do we know i mean is he really
ill or is this just wishful thinking the
thought being that you know he's on his
way out he's 69 and um he's launched
this war now because it could be his
last hurrah well he still can yes on the
7th of october he will be 70 that's his
birthday the 7th of october
and um he is known to hit the botox
quite heavily um i always say that he's
trying to embalm himself while he's
still alive he does take a lot of botox
um he is
he he moves around with doctors there's
known to be a little team of doctors who
are never far away and it's said that he
leaves meetings at frequent intervals to
go and consult with somebody um i
suspect that he's only a hypochondriac
to be honest um it is it's often said
look has he got has he got cancer he's
got pancreatic cancer he's got
parkinson's disease when you see him
in these clips that we're seeing
increasingly frequently now that kovid
is over and he's now coming out of the
uh the shadows as it were where he's
been for over two years and he's making
it clear that he's in control he's doing
this he's doing that he looks all right
and again i've spoken to a number of
people who said you cannot detect
parkinson's disease from the way he
walks you cannot detect symptoms of
cancer just by looking at the
photographs so i you know these stories
will circulate
um but there's no convincing evidence if
if he is ill
or becomes ill that would be one way out
for russia to say that the president has
stepped down and the the war will now be
prosecuted by you know nikola patruchev
who's every bit as nasty as he is but at
least it would be a change of face
uh which the west might then be able to
do something with but that's just a side
possibility really okay well let's uh
talk now about the alliances that
they've built up namely with china i
guess al asks is russia sourcing weapons
of munitions from other countries or is
it purely relying on its own reserves is
it is it getting anything from china and
others yeah it's trying um
what it most needs is components and so
a lot of soviet equipment a lot of old
soviet equipment and some more modern
russian equipment has been sold around
the world in the middle east to india
to some african countries and the
russians are scouring their customers to
try and get some of it back if not whole
weapon system certainly ammunition which
they're pretty short of precision
ammunition and some of the other more
specialized things and they have they've
we know that they've asked china uh
quite early on actually after about a
month fighting for weapons and the
chinese have
not said no but they haven't helped
either it's believed that china has
given them some help of a relatively low
level type of not non-lethal but things
which are not directly
ordnance direct weapons
so yes they are trying to source mainly
components in the rest of the world and
yes they are relying on their own
reserve stocks they're dipping deep into
their reserve stocks now and so we're
not we're now seeing some of these t-62
tanks what are these these are older
versions the older version 1960s version
real cold war versions of tanks and they
are now appearing on the in the battle
space um
so yeah the russians are struggling and
sanctions of course have had a big
effect on their own armaments industry
because their tank factories the two big
tank factories that they've got are
almost at a standstill for lack of
components they because they employ you
know they get their components basically
from the west i have done okay and what
about the fighting forces themselves i
mean we've heard particularly in the in
the last week about considerable numbers
of conscripts being used by russia
is bruce says is it mainly the army
composed of conscripts
in in in total terms about 50 50
which is to say that the the peacetime
army which is the russians are relying
on because officially this is still
peacetime this is a special military
operation not a war
so putin hasn't mobilized and the
peacetime army is 280 000. and every
year around about april there is a new
conscript um intake of 135 this year 134
500 i think it was so you know about
half of 280 000 is replaced every year
so another group comes in for a seven
month training period and over that
period about half the army leaves so
this peacetime army is in a total is in
a a period of transition and one year
conscription is is no good to anybody
you know you train you spend seven
months training somebody
and then they do five months of
of work
and then they're back in the civilian
sector now what the russians tried to do
is during that period when somebody's
conscripted they say look your life is a
conscript it's miserable isn't it we
know it's miserable actually we make it
miserable for you sign a contract become
a professional soldier for two years and
your life will improve from tomorrow and
so what they've been trying to do is
bring the conscripts in persuade them
pressurize them to sign contracts to
increase the size of their army but they
haven't been terribly successful and
putin promised at the beginning of this
operation that he would not employ
conscripts in the forces fighting in
ukraine and that promise has gone by the
board because there are lots of
conscripts in ukraine
uh lastly in this section uh back to the
the aims of the russian forces and um
stuart says if russia wins these
southern regions let me add in the
eastern ones as well will they then try
for kiev again perhaps with chemical
weapons or nukes because of a lack of
ground troops so in terms of objectives
if the donbass is secured the bits of
the south say they don't go for odessa
could they go for kiev again
it is certainly the case that president
putin wants to eliminate ukraine from
the map as an independent state he wants
ukrainian territory and people to be
part of russia the way he believes
mistakenly for because he's got a very
eccentric view of russian history for
the last thousand years
but he believes that ukrainians are
really just little russians that's what
they used to call them little russians
um and so that is that will remain his
ultimate objective it's been his
objective since at least 2008 and we can
we can you know look at that in the
speeches he's made the things he said
so that's his ultimate objective so yes
he would like to get kiev at some point
would he launch a chemical or a nuclear
attack against gear i don't know i mean
kiev is one of the
jewels in the crown
of slavic culture kia was founded in the
year 482
so it's more than 1 500 years old it's
older than moscow you know kiev is the
center of slavic culture which gave us
russia
would yeah would he destroy it with a
nuclear weapon if he tried to would the
order be obeyed we've talked about that
before i suspect not in the case of kiev
so no i don't think and chemical weapons
we have to say are remarkably
inefficient as weapons on the
battlefield they they really don't work
terribly well they work
only in very specific specific
circumstances
when they when the british first used
chemical weapons in the first world war
the germans used gas first in 1915 when
the british used gas later on in 1950 in
the battle of lewis they gas themselves
it's very unpredictable very
unpredictable anyway
so yes kiev is still a target but not
with chemical or nuclear weapons okay um
we'll take a break now much more about
russia's objectives in the second half
of this special program you're watching
sky news tonight coming up we're going
to be discussing the international
response to the war
as president zielenski of ukraine makes
another appeal for long-range weapons
[Music]
welcome back to this special program
answering your questions about the war
in ukraine we're going to turn now to
the international response to the war
professor michael clark is here to
answer all your questions and uh here's
the first one for this section kevin
asks if his world leaders predicted we
knew putin was going to invade ukraine
why did the west not stop power weapons
and train the ukrainian military ahead
of the invasion well i suppose to a
certain extent the the west did
start that process yeah after 2014 that
process began and the british were in
the lead on that with operation orbital
was what it was called and we trained 22
000 ukrainian soldiers which were
basically an officer call
and the americans were also heavily
involved in that what we didn't do until
much later on was provide lethal weapons
we provided equipment but the uh there
was a sort of reluctance to provoke
russia by giving lethal weapons to
ukraine but what they did i mean
ukrainians were so um they were wiped
out in 2014 their military was
undermined by uh by effectively traitors
who were pro-russian and just gave
things away you know gave away territory
and so on they were on the floor in 2014
which is why putin expected to be on the
floor this time and the ukrainians had
the good sense to go back to basics and
they said what do we need to do
and british and american or american
british trainers with some help from
other european and nato nations helped
them to build up a western force from
the ground up they did the basics so
they started from scratch and produced
what is now a very western style force
that does things in a very western way
which is one reason only one reason why
they're doing so well um so yes quite a
lot was done however this question of if
world leaders knew well yeah i mean
american and british intelligence knew
back in october last year that this was
building up to an invasion and they told
the world in december yes that's when
they were in town
and they told ukrainians in october but
the fact is that the ukrainians didn't
want to believe it i mean they sort of
half believed it but they didn't want to
and other intelligence services were
saying the opposite and french
intelligence services in particular were
actually saying no no we're closer to
russia we know the russians because of
the relationship between france and
russia has always been historically
closed we know what they're thinking
they're not going to do this this is all
bluff and bluster they really won't do
it and by the time we get to january
this year when the potential is really
building up there was a sort of a war of
briefing and to be honest i mean french
intelligence seemed to be briefing
against american and british
intelligence and the ukrainians weren't
sure what to do and i say that
live on tv because a i knew it to be
true and b the head of french
intelligence was dismissed um
you know by president macron
as a result of this problem that they
got it completely and utterly wrong so
the ukrainians i think were faced with a
real dilemma and they there was a degree
of avoidance a degree of just denial but
it wasn't that they were unprepared but
they they could have preferred prepared
better earlier and we could have given
them more lethal aid better earlier and
i know again for a fact the mod our
ministry of defense was trying to give
them weapons from 2014 onwards and the
foreign office and downing street just
wouldn't have it
because of this they're trying to make
it
in the signal they weren't absolutely
wrong in saying that but they were
making a judgment don't give them lethal
weapons well let's talk about the here
and now and this continued cry from
president zielinski for these long-range
weapons and uh sue asks why the uk and
the us dragging their heels on promised
long-range weapons it promises a promise
are the uk and the u.s dragging their
feet or other countries as well no i
mean the the ukrainians are getting the
howitzers that they need these um you
know houses with a range of 20 odd miles
these heavy howitzers they're not
getting any of ours ours are the as9
tiers which are very old now and we're
getting rid of them ourselves and i
think it wouldn't be sensible to send
them but they're much better how it and
we're re re-equipping there are much
better howitzers uh in the business the
particularly the german one uh the uh
the the pan the panzerhaubitsa
uh 2000 best in the world and the
american called a triple the m triple
seven and they've got apparently 90 of
these uh m triple sevens they've only
got a handful of the panzer hour bits um
and they've got they are getting some
multiple launch rocket systems but again
only a few a handful the americans are
sending seven units but with lots of
rockets and we said we're sending three
units with lots of rockets now if the
ukrainians have only got 10 actual
launch systems i guarantee that in a
month's time of fighting those they'll
be lucky if they've still got two still
operational because the russians be
looking for these things if they know
they're there
and in in battle
you you lose equipment you know a lot
the attrition rates as they say are very
very high so it's undoubtedly the case
they are getting longer range weapons
promises are made and these things are
beginning to arrive but not in anything
like the numbers that they really need
they've got they're getting plenty of
howitzers but the things that will make
the difference are the multiple launch
rocket systems which have a range of
about 60 or 70 miles and can have a
range if you put a missile on them of
180 miles not just a rocket but a
missile now we're not going to give them
missiles but we're giving them rockets
um but they've said um aristov who is
the uh adviser to the defense ministry
in kiev said look we need 60. and i
think yeah i mean pal you need 60 in the
first tranche and then you're going to
need 60 more after that they need them
now um
i suppose a broader question coming up
now this one just i suppose about the
about the support are europe doing their
bit or just doing a lot of talking as
usual well different countries are
taking different approaches yeah
i mean you know europe the european
union and we see that you know there's
uh uh slavonda land who is the president
of the commission with zielinski i guess
that's a photograph from the last couple
of days
i mean only today
she in the european commission said we
are recommending to the european council
which is the heads of government that
ukraine now be given candidate status
in the eu as an eu member that's
something the ukrainians have really
wanted that would be a big political
message whether she's overreaching
herself or she has done in the past i
don't know but the commission is going
to recommend to the government to 27
governments that ukraine be given
candidate status which means that it
will get a lot more help in economic
terms which believe me it's it needs
so there is that side of it also the eu
is on its sixth round of sanctions and
is now negotiating a seventh round of
sanctions
they've got problems with hungary who
because the hungarians all ban in
hungary uh prime minister orban doesn't
want to go in for a seventh round but
they're trying to negotiate that so that
sanctions have been pretty important and
individually lots of european countries
like the netherlands and spain uh and uh
romania and bulgaria they're sending the
material that they've got and
interestingly one of the things that
britain is doing which was only uh
mentioned in passing about a week ago is
that the raf has it says has delivered
it caused thousands it doesn't say how
many thousands of tons of munitions from
one european country to
ukraine to poland one assumes where they
can go so we're not just sending our own
weapons the raf is using it using its
transport fleet some of it to move other
european weapons around to help the
ukrainians
so the raf is doing something else which
you know nobody seems to have picked up
question here then from lee about that
about the the weapons being supplied in
all their forms um
how do western arms make it to the front
line intact when they have to travel
across the whole of ukraine don't the
russians have intelligence as to the
route they take aren't they vulnerable
yeah you know at the beginning of this
process i thought that would be the case
and when talking to people in the
ministry of defense they've said no
they're quite relaxed about it you said
partly because there's lots of the the
railways system is still operational
it's very dense railway system in
ukraine very traditional one it's a
different gauge for everybody else's
which you know it's the old soviet gauge
which isn't helpful but never mind um so
they've got these very dense railway
system so that they can move things
around the russians find it quite hard
to attack the railway system
um and it can be repaired quite quickly
the road system is also it's more sparse
but as we were saying earlier on the
russians find it quite difficult to
attack moving targets so
um they are getting the stuff through
and there's a degree of subterfuge
involved and yes the russians are you
know they're using their intelligence
and occasionally as we've seen in the
last week they look as if they've scored
some pretty one or two big hits on
weapons stockpiles that have come
straight from the west and they've
destroyed brand new systems you know
quite big ones so i mean the russians
are getting some success in this but in
general
most of what is being sent is finding
its way reasonably quickly
a matter of several days not 24 hours
but several days it's finding its way to
the front line okay uh next question
this one from buster about uh how far
the west is prepared to go uh how far
are you getting the west willing to go
to secure victory in ukraine uh well you
know not as far as putting boots on the
ground of course yeah and it's going to
have to go a lot further than it's gone
so far in my view
i think i mean i think what buster is is
kind of implying i don't know if he was
thinking about this
um is that putin if putin gets most of
the donbass in the next couple of months
i think he will offer some sort of peace
deal or some sort of truth some sort of
ceasefire arrangement
and then the western
consensus which has been very tough so
far very determined will tend to split
and then we'll find out how far the uk
and the west is willing to go because
then we've got to decide a question that
you and i have talked about before both
privately and on camera you know is the
west trying to end the war or help
ukraine really win it
if we're trying to end the war that
might happen reasonably quickly
if we're trying to help ukraine win this
war for the sake of
civilized behavior and the international
order and legality and so on then we're
going to have to do a lot more than
we're doing at the moment we're going to
have to be prepared to take more risks
take some hurt ourselves both in the
effect of sanctions and in the economic
downside of of re-militarizing
what we are prepared to produce and send
to ukraine
and possibly um you know i think we're
facing a series of thresholds between
now and next year which we'll either
cross or we won't to get a bit more
directly involved a bit more okay uh
back to the situation as it stands and
how it may develop this from jay if the
donbass is lost to russia will the west
continue to arm ukraine in order to
retake the donbass region this is the
issue you were touching on earlier about
the ukrainian's ability to to fight the
russians to a standstill but not
actually yeah but not throw them out
yeah and that's why to to actually
conduct a strategic offensive which is
be to actually throw the russians out of
large parts of the areas they've taken
certainly since the 24th of february the
ukrainians need more heavy equipment
they need more more equipment that can
be used in the offensive they need to
rework their command structure and
they've got to bring you know quite
large forces of their troops who are
very nicely dispersed and working very
well in relatively small units
relatively and they've got to start to
bring them together for these big
offensives
that will take some time and the west
would have to back that we'd have to
back it now at the moment everyone is
saying in the west we'll do whatever the
ukrainians want if they if they decide
to go for a ceasefire then through
gritted teeth we would support them
because they're the ones doing the
fighting if they decide no they're going
to fight on to free to free up their
territory we ought to support that as
well and that's easy to say at the
moment
but it will it be so easy to say in
august and september and october when
other things are getting difficult what
about another way of getting i mentioned
their boots on the ground uh this from
mark should more british veterans
joining the fight with ukraine to show a
sign of strength and uh they're the
images we're showing of course are the
the two british veterans being sentenced
to death in the breakaway don bass
region we know of others that have been
killed in the battles aslan and the
pinner yeah
um yeah so aiden azlin isn't it and uh
sean pinner
i mean point one is you know real battle
spaces are absolutely no place for
amateurs
or you know willing recruits who got no
experience at all which you know these
two guys were quite experienced
um
if anybody is
determined to help the best thing they
can do is to go to the border go to
poland or romania and help with the the
background aspects and the you know next
pair of hands can be very helpful but if
untrained people end up in the battle
area they'll either you know they'll get
hurt or killed very quickly or they'll
be just used as cannon fodder because
there's not much else that they can do
veterans is a dif are a different issue
and the government is not encouraging
veterans to go despite what the foreign
secretary said i think on the 27th of
february
speaking without thinking i'm afraid um
the government is not encouraging people
to go because even if you're a veteran i
mean these two guys were there for four
years yeah and so they're suddenly
injured they were integrated in
absolutely
aslan in the marines and pino was in
different units i think but both of them
were proper ukrainian soldiers who were
taking ukrainian pay and were you know
they happened to be foreign nationals
just as fijians and samoans serve in the
british army foreign nationals serve in
the british army perfectly legally and
they were foreign nationals serving in
the ukrainian army
but veteran you know veterans going out
now to fight to help again it's hard to
fit them in in a way that makes any
military sense because even if they're
quite used to military life
they're just one person with a different
set of training standards and a
different sort of way of doing things
different weapons they've been trained
on not the ak-47s and so on it's
unlikely that they can make that much
difference nobody knows how many british
soldiers or british individuals might be
there they think somewhere between 50
and 100 they think maybe 20 have been
killed but those these are just sort of
order of magnitude guesses from what we
pick up okay michael uh for the time
being thanks we're going to take another
break you're watching sky news coming up
next we'll discuss what could happen
next in ukraine and weather
an end maybe
some way in sight
[Music]
welcome back we're going to end the
program now by discussing what we should
expect in ukraine in the coming weeks
and months and whether an end to the war
could be in sight as you know professor
michael clark is still with me here
answering your questions uh this one
then from matt asking just that the
situation in ukraine appears to be
deteriorating certainly in the east what
might the next couple of months bring
well if i had to guess i mean as i say
that you know war is is more
unpredictable than sport by and large um
and
i i would expect that the ukrainians
will continue to fight for the donbass
fiercely
and that the russians won't get all of
the donbass but they they'll get luhansk
uh and and what they've got of of uh
donetsk and maybe a bit more done yet
but i suspect that the ukrainians will
actually make gains in in
splitting the russians up in kharkiv in
the second city further north
and they might i think the ukrainians
really want to get kirschen back and so
i think that in the next couple of
months the ukrainians will as we've said
fight the russians to a standstill in
the donbass and the russians might say
well that's that's okay we've got as
much as we want but they may well then
find that they are losing
uh in the south and the ukrainians i
think will make some gains however those
are all sort of tactical gains what
we're really looking at is a kind of a
stalemate between both sides and i'm
sure given the the usage rates the
attrition that we're talking about the
losses of i'm i'm of troops i'm sure
that both sides will take a pause
because that's what happens you know war
goes in fits and fits and starts it has
to and i think there will be a there'll
be a pause before
a ceasefire or just well i think i think
the russians will offer some sort of
ceasefire in order to put pressure on
the west um and i don't think
if the ukrainians don't accept it i
don't think we should pressure them to
accept it but i think you know
ceasefires are one thing but actually
pauses
acknowledge pauses between both sides or
another
what about the economy though we talk
about the situation the war situation
deteriorating clearly the ukrainian
economy is in a pile of state can the
ukrainian economy survive andrew asks
considering the mariupol steel works not
under their control little wheat is
being farmed and so many other
money-making facilities being attacked
and destroyed well uh the good news on
agriculture is that an astonishing 90
of the crop for the next crop has been
sown because most of the agricultural
areas of ukraine have not been
particularly affected by the war but the
industrial areas have because the
industrial areas are those in the east
of the country from uh uh chernihev uh
right down to mariupol really
and the ukrainians are looking at a drop
in their gdp at the moment of 45 percent
which is catastrophic
and the cost of reconstruction if the
war stopped now
the cost of reconstruction is generally
estimated order of magnitude is about
600 billion dollars
and somebody's gonna have to pay for
that
um and of course the the eu and the g7
are now thinking well the russians
should pay for it and you know there is
one trillions worth of russian private
assets in the western world
and should they be seized in order to
pay for this there are some big issues
there the not least the legal issue on
on what legal basis you seize it but
that's the nature of the of the problem
the ukrainian economy
is going to be on its knees at the end
of this exactly is that you know the
british economy is completely bankrupt
in 1945 because we devoted everything to
fighting what was for us a total war
that's exactly what the ukrainians are
doing so the fact that they've lost 45
of their gdp is only the where they are
now
somebody
you know the western world has got to
actually help them through the war
however long it lasts and then we've got
to devise some way of helping to rebuild
them and everyone is working on well
what can we what can we make sure the
russians provide to rebuild some of the
damage well our next question asks how
do we get to that point and i suppose
it's based on what we were discussing
earlier what you were saying there about
a pause would ukraine settle for the
loss of the donbass region if it brought
about a lasting peace deal and i'd add
to that how do you know it would be a
loss yeah i think they wouldn't and i'm
sure they wouldn't i mean they might
they might have to acquiesce in the loss
of the donbass but then they will not
accept it because they don't believe
that russia bears them anything other
than ill will they do believe that
russia wants to destroy them there will
be a pause to regroup exactly i mean
they've been peace deals signed before
haven't they absolutely anything they
agreed to would be on the basis that it
was temporary as far as kiev is
concerned because they fundamentally
don't trust russia under putin and
probably russia under whoever comes
after putin i think we're talking about
a third generation of leadership before
we can get back on terms with russia
which i would put sometime probably in
the 2030s
another question as we uh imagine what
an end to the war might look like and
this from the from the russian point of
view given what putin has promised the
russian people uh given russia's
infamous history of propaganda is it
possible even if ukraine wins the war
that putin will claim otherwise and say
actually they won and achieved exactly
what they set out i mean in a way that's
kind of a a messy peace deal isn't it
where you can both take something away
yeah it's it's what they will say anyway
um and
i mean if president putin says well you
know we've got enough of the donbass now
this is i've preserved the integrity of
the russian minorities and the donbass
who were suffering from all these nazis
in kiev who were terrorizing them and
that's his narrative a the rest of the
world will see that's not the case b the
donbass will not be peaceful any more
than the the land bridge will be
peaceful around kershaw i mean the
ukrainians will keep resisting the
russians will not will not be able to as
it would go home and just leave a
civilian administration there they'll
need to keep their troops there so it'll
be this grumbling war and while that's
going on the world will be saying oh yes
well this war was was undertaken to tell
nato not to enlarge and nato has now got
quite a lot bigger because sweden and
finland have joined nato which are the
two most important new members since
1994
and russia is a pariah and russia is
under sanctions for as long as you're in
control mr putin that's a great
strategic victory that is you know i
remain the master strategist everything
you wanted to achieve
is is actually going exactly the
opposite direction and a lot of people
are paying for it with their lives well
carol follows on from that then carol
asks this how will russia be accepted
after the war and it's precisely the
point you'd be making not just today
michael it is putin
is the big problem if he's still there
how will the rest of the world regard
russia yeah
sanctions will remain for as long as
putin is there i'm sure about that and
you know putin may not be there for so
much longer uh we're waiting for some
sort of coup to take place so you know
you can't guarantee whether it'll be in
three months time or three years or five
years time um and that and that poor
individual is um vasily
who is the um
the un ambassador russia's u.n
ambassador and he has probably the worst
job in the world because he's the one
who has to say stupid things he has to
deny that any of this is happening he
has to pretend that all of the bombing
in mario poll was done by the ukrainians
that they're bombing themselves that
they're killing their own women and
children in order to blame the russians
and he's a bit like um zorin
ambassador zorin in 1962 in the cuban
missile crisis the you know the russians
didn't tell him what was happening he
didn't know what was happening and um
adelaide stevenson he suddenly said what
about this and what about this and
zombies no it's not happening not
happening and then adelaide stevenson
went to the blackboard and he unveiled
all of these photographs of the missiles
in cuba so what is this mr ambassador
what is this what is this and he made
him look really ridiculous and nebenzia
to me he looks like a latter day zorran
um i'm i'm just waiting for the guy to
defect you said there michael you're
expecting the coup
i mean anytime soon that putin will be
removed
he yeah he's got nowhere to go uh russia
has got nowhere to go under his
leadership and this war will get worse
for russia even if he succeeds in the
donbass or even if he was to succeed you
know as we said in in taking odessa
which i don't think you will um
the people around him are beginning to
lose very heavily and although they
depend on him for their kleptocracy i
mean russia is a mafia state and again
that's a that's not my phrase that's the
phrase of most good analysts it's it's
become a mafia state and so the only way
that the people around him can preserve
any of their privileges and wealth
eventually is to remove him now who will
start that we don't know because he's
also running a reign of terror which is
now
every bit as bad as stalin's reign of
terror was
up to the point where stalin died in
1953.
michael so you know
the future for him the outcome is
certain the timing is uncertain